[Music]
so do you guys know who
damn i mean that this is going to be
obvious but you guys know cain velasquez
is nah yup okay so i know you do yeah
big fan so who is he he's one of the
greatest heavyweight ufc fighters ever
he uh he's a huge dude but dances around
like a cat and that's what he had to say
oh that's the guy that
yeah oh yeah i know this one thanks joe
great
yeah
my bad yeah let me let you do your job
let me let you do your job
yeah he's been charged he's been charged
with attempted murder
after um
so there was a shooting on monday night
in san jose this is this last monday the
crazy thing is is him uh daniel cormier
his coach everyone from that camp from
aka in san jose they're known to be
stand-up dudes so like when i first saw
it on my instagram feed i'm like what
the [ __ ] came velazquez shot someone
like they're they're like
yeah they're like good sports you know
like they they
they win they lose doesn't matter like
everyone likes them and so it just
really caught me off guard to see well
some might say that this is a stand-up
thing to do yeah in my world it is by
the way because when it first the story
first came out
it just says came in velasquez arrested
for attempted murder like whoa and then
the whole time i'm like attempted and
kind of like going back to what uh bart
said about cain velasquez like he is
like uh he's he's a really good example
for the sport everyone's like a really
good guy stand up guy yeah so when you
heard that you're like something must
have happened he must have
defended himself or whatever the case
may be but when you heard that when you
find out what the actual story was it is
kind of [ __ ] up
it's very [ __ ] up so he's being he's
being charged with 10 counts that could
he could carry more than 20 years of
jail time 20 to life dude uh yeah
attempted murder shooting at an
an occupied motor vehicle or aircraft
three counts of assault with a firearm
three counts of assault with a deadly
weapon willful discharging a firearm
from a vehicle carrying a loaded firearm
with intent to commit a felony that's
like all those charges for one one thing
but it was also registered all the when
you hear the legal jargon it sounds
[ __ ] crazy but when you hear the
story of i believe his daughter um used
to go to this babysitter
and the babysitter's son who's
40-something has molested his daughter
over a hundred times i think or niece
yeah over 100
and then his niece is only like four
years old
so that's like when you hear when you
hear that and then you kind of hear what
like what actually happened you're like
i can see how someone's like if they
lost it yeah they maybe drove down the
street [ __ ] that [ __ ] you get in
the car i'm chasing after you i believe
he rammed his truck into that they have
it on video too yeah and then uh
and so like when he pulls out his gun
he's trying to blast him and of course
he misses then you are endangering
innocent bystanders you are shooting
other people there are a whole list of
things but when you're just thinking
about the justice he's trying to serve
you're like i kind of feel for what he's
doing yeah i think it's a good jury yeah
hope he gets a jury that understands so
what do you think will happen like when
he goes to court do you think is there
any wiggle room for anything like that
in this context it's so tough in san
jose i don't know bro
he's probably gonna see jail time for
sure right because you're gonna argue
right that this is a crime of passion
yeah right because he finds out like his
niece says hey this guy eugene takes me
into a bathroom and he starts touching
my genitals
and then he's he's being charged with
that right
towards the moment and he has priors too
it's the same type of issue over a
hundred times yeah so crazy
that the incident had occurred over 100
times uh and that
the kid said that he witnessed other
kids going to the bathroom with the same
guy
so yeah um and and it just so happened
that she was running a daycare here and
she had no idea that he was doing that
yeah it's like a grandma running a
daycare and the sun comes in and out to
help or whatever but then the sun is
doing all kinds of but he's claiming
that you know
i didn't do anything he's like yeah
sometimes kids would have helped they
needed help with their pants
when they didn't have them on correctly
so he's saying that that's what he was
doing
yeah yeah it's weird who knows that's
[ __ ] weird and then his mom
the mom of the accused molester right
says that she doesn't doesn't buy it so
there's that environment perhaps right
yeah she's like in denial in denial
she's running a daycare this [ __ ] with
her business if it's true yeah there's a
lot going on all right
and what sucks is this isn't a normal
guy this is guy that's
classified as one of the most dangerous
dudes in the world he's a heavyweight
champion so it's just so many like
factors that kind of like dramatize the
story even more when the story is
already crazy so for the molester he has
priors of molestation already but he's
like oh but that those were happening
but this time it's different is that
what you're trying to say like those
were probably those were the balls this
one's the pants right like is he like no
i was actually trying to fix this kid's
pants oh yeah before i i was molesting
people but not this time like like the
[ __ ] is he is this this is [ __ ] crazy
yeah because joggers are really hard to
work with now it's a modern cat yeah
yeah the old school trousers are way
easier it's out of his generation he
doesn't understand this yeah um so they
haven't i haven't seen anything about if
he died or not i don't think the guy
died he shot the stepfather in the arm i
think oh cause they were were they like
driving together so the stepfather
dipped with the accused molester
and apparently my book man yeah dude and
apparently kane was like chasing him and
there's like some video of that and then
kane shot i guess the step father in the
arm
he's fine he was treated all good
but
the damage is done he's probably gonna
go to jail for a real long time but just
[ __ ] right like it's so crazy to think
about you know what's weird is like if
that happened to you where like where
your daughter was molested
it's almost like
based on what society has taught us like
kids never recover from that yeah like
there's always gonna be some kind of
[ __ ] up trauma i i feel like i would
do the same [ __ ] because the least i
could do
is at least show that
that kid
that at least i tried to even it out
somehow yeah
you know what i mean yeah but then also
at the same time
are you also hurting that kid's future
by just not [ __ ] being there
because now you're in jail yeah so
that's what dana white said he says i
obviously feel sorry for him and his
family
it's a horrible thing i don't know
enough details to speak on it but from
what i've heard we all say we'd do it if
it ever happened to us kane did it yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] that's a gangster
statement isn't it that's a really great
statement part of me wishes right you
hear this stuff and you're like man if
you just swore to like obviously he the
moment and so crazy but he just moved a
little bit in silence i bet you could
have still got the job done i think if
you if you can even picture yourself
maybe doing it hypothetically
if it actually happened and you had the
tools and the time you would 100 do it
reflexively like by reflex you would do
it
the only way you would is if you waited
i think most guys would just
go for it you're not gonna have the
presence of mind to like go like okay
calm down steve i need to go in the dark
web
i know i wish though
unless you pre-planned it where like
that's the protocol in place for when
that [ __ ] does happen
that's like not a crime of passion at
that point that's like a pre-meditation
meditating yeah
what oh yeah how how long did he know
this for i don't know i don't know how
long i don't think there's any other
details out there not in many details
about it like dana white said but it's
just all all we have is this is the
results of everything that's happened so
far also what kind of signal does this
send if let's say
kane um
like his story is true right because we
also don't know that's just his side but
let's say his story is true
he he does get 20 years or a life
then the signal that it sends out to the
world is if
your
kid
does get molested
you're not allowed to do anything about
it and you just kind of have to trust
that justice will serve itself which who
does that well remember that texas case
where the dad um he killed the assailant
that was molesting his daughter but he
caught them in the act
so he in ways of preventing the crime he
actually did got acquitted because it's
also texas too
i don't think california will ever no
way they're never on the side of [ __ ]
no they they always are on the side of
the of the perpetrator
and that's what's scary because like
so you got to look at it case by case
the way our justice system works right
it's like he's going to be charged for
the molestation case right and then
kane's going to be charged on the uh
attempted murder case separately they
don't see it as one connection
so depending on how much evidence they
have on the molestation case and all
these things he might even get out way
[ __ ] earlier than kay does so yeah
which is so crazy well that signals to
the world you can molest as many kids as
you [ __ ] want you're gonna get a slap
on the wrist
while if you try to avenge that then
you'll [ __ ] go to jail forever but i
guess the
it's it's like trying to create an
overall picture if you try to zoom out
it's trying to create a society
that is um not harmful in general to
everyone right so like if you want an
eye for an eye situation but if you're
like shooting guns like you know trying
to catch your bad guy you [ __ ] hit a
grandma or whatever like that's also
[ __ ] up so they're trying to also
prevent like acts of passion i guess
coming out of revenge so that means the
poetic justices whatever the
crime that was committed that you have
to exact revenge for that's the limit to
the crime that you can project so if
you're fighting molestation you got to
molest the molester i think so i think
so that way it can at least be how does
that always happen in this room
and there's there's more than one person
agreeing
we're
yeah
yeah i mean like i think that's the best
thing you can actually do is find a
situation
where you don't bother anybody else or
risk anybody else you don't have to
damage any property or whatever give us
the details okay
so we'll have a
a a squad a justice squad just a squad i
like it and they'll go out and if
they're proven guilty a militia if you
will
maybe
or maybe you call it a a rescue squad
okay i see a wrestling squad
militia
it could be an ice cream truck with just
the door open and he's driving down the
street he goes come here eduardo
because he's drawn to ice cream trucks
and he has to go in
like oh it's just a good guy's militia
you know it's another another
super sad aspect of this is that like so
we all know like one of the worst things
about crimes against kids is that they
[ __ ] pay for it their whole life yeah
yeah and and sometimes they end up
redoing the same thing
it's like they have such less hope but
then the even worst part
is that
because this is a high profile case now
there's no anonymity for this kid to go
on in life and like at least
some kids when it happens to them no one
needs to know and they can kind of
deal with it how they want yeah but it's
like everyone's gonna [ __ ] know now
like that like historically this
happened to you and i think because san
jose is uh i think that's where it's it
happened right and and came velazquez
and that whole team they're really
embedded in the san jose community too
so like everyone knows who they are
right everyone knows where the gym is
but i would like to think that hopefully
he has some connections with like you
know the government like the local
government until you say the mob but but
to like ryan's point imagine it's like
now that kids got to grow up and not
only does everybody know about the case
and all that stuff but even in the worst
case scenario it's like
you know
he goes to jail for a long time that's
maybe that that kid will feel like it's
that kid's fault you know what i mean
or yeah and now it's bigger
like everyone knows what happened to you
i think the best thing that we can do is
build basements all over in different
cities for things like this right you
grab the guy when justice isn't served
by our justice system and it failed you
put them in the basement you lock them
up and then you wait until your own kid
is old enough to make the decisions of
what they want to do to that person
that's pretty baller that's a really
good idea because it's like you know
think about a job unless you're getting
a house and being like oh this is handy
has a basement
it's locked steve it's not open
but all the houses have basements joe no
one a one does okay
for this purpose okay okay the city
basement the city basement i got the
city base basement ship this is the base
that's that's what's hard is like you
don't know if like even though in your
mind of poetic justice that does seem
like [ __ ] sweet you just kill the guy
that raped your kid but like in the long
run and the long-term effects is that
what that kid would have wanted like you
have no clue how that if it's turning
out for the best and also in a state of
like rage and passion
if he was just shooting a firearm out of
the car
into wide open street like who knows who
else he could have potentially hit to
you know that street to be fair look
pretty empty and he could have like
accidentally shot another like molester
or something like that since
california's still pro molester you know
that's true dude is california
california is [ __ ] probably how long
it is bro if you go on the map isn't
[ __ ] red dots all over the place dude
it's pretty peaceful we did the [ __ ]
whole surge look we did the saxophone
research looked at this area what the
[ __ ] actually looked like [ __ ]
verizon coverage zone
i can tell you those are good
little tiny uh side story super short my
uh i i dated this girl who was molested
by your uncle when she was a kid
and then uh
she
her parents never did [ __ ] about it
when she was like 18 did they yell at
her about it because uh yeah yeah they
did they actually did they actually were
like no that never happened yeah they
were matter of fact accusing him she
turned 18. uh she got her hands on a gun
and she decided she wanted to go find
her uncle and kill him
and then it was like her dad's friend
and her dad had long passed away so she
didn't really know what happened to this
friend
uh you know when you grow up there's
that uncle that you just called my uncle
but it's just like your dad's friend so
she finally finds him
uh goes to his house and finds out that
he's also passed away
and she and then she uh called me and
was like i just
would have made the biggest mistake of
my life holy [ __ ] but yeah the dude was
already dead but she went to [ __ ]
actually kill insane
dude you have the craziest stories bro i
grew up in the [ __ ] late 90s
hey t-mobile huh
great coverage
you